This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vidantam. In the early 1980s, a couple of researchers wrote an article in The Atlantic that would have far-reaching consequences. The article introduced a new idea about crime and policing. It was called Broken Windows. The idea was simple. A broken window is a sign of a neglected community. And a neglected community is a place
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。在20世纪80年代初，《大西洋月刊》上发表了一对研究人员撰写的一篇文章，这产生了深远的影响。这篇文章引入了一个关于犯罪和警务的新理念。它被称为“破窗效应”。这个想法很简单。一扇破了的窗户是一个社区遭到忽视的标志。而遭到忽视的社区是一个
where crime can thrive. The researchers said, if police could fix the small problems, the big ones would disappear. So the broken windows theory was this magical solution that basically everybody could like. It quickly became seen as a panacea for crime. Today we explore how ideas sometimes get away from those who invented them.
犯罪能够滋生的地方。研究人员表示，如果警察能够解决小问题，大问题就会消失。因此，“破窗理论”是一个基本上每个人都会喜欢的神奇解决方案。它很快被视为解决犯罪问题的灵丹妙药。今天，我们探讨各种理念有时是如何脱离它们的创立者的。
And then are taken to places that were never intended. It's a beautiful story and it's a myth. Our story begins in 1969. The psychologist, Philips Zimbato ran an interesting experiment. He abandoned two cars on the street, one in a mostly poor, crime-ridden section of the Bronx in New York City, and the other in an affluent neighborhood in Palo Alto, California. Both cars were left without license plates, parked with the hoods up. With 10 minutes of leaving the car in the Bronx, passers-by began taking things of value. The car was quickly stripped for parts.
然后被带向了从未预料到的方向。这是一个美好的故事，也是一个神话。我们的故事始于1969年。心理学家菲利普·津巴多进行了一项有趣的实验。他在街头遗弃了两辆汽车，一辆在纽约市布朗克斯区一个主要贫困、犯罪猖獗的地段，另一辆在加利福尼亚州帕洛阿尔托的一个富裕社区。两辆车都没有悬挂车牌，引擎盖敞开着停放。在将车留在布朗克斯区不到10分钟的时间里，路人就开始拿走有价值的东西。这辆车很快就被拆光了零件。
Then, the random destruction began. Windows were smashed. The car was destroyed. But for more than a week in Palo Alto, the other car remained untouched. Until Zombardo himself gave the car a smash with a sledgehammer and once the car was damaged it became fair game. This is George L. Kelling.
接着，随意的破坏开始了。窗户被砸碎了。汽车被毁坏了。但在帕洛阿尔托，另一辆车在一个多星期的时间里完好无损。直到津巴多本人用大锤砸了这辆车，一旦汽车遭到损坏，它就成了人人可欺的目标。这是乔治·L·凯林。
He's a senior fellow at the Manhattan Institute. In 1982, I co-authored an article called Broken Windows with James Q. Wilson. This article has gotten considerable attention in the policing and non-policing world. George was fascinated by what had happened in Palo Alto. Once the car was damaged, things played out exactly as they had in the Bronx. The idea that once disorder begins, it doesn't matter what the neighborhood is, things can begin to get out of control. George reasoned that the same thing might be true for communities as a whole.
他是曼哈顿研究所的高级研究员。1982年，我与詹姆斯·Q·威尔逊合著了一篇名为《破窗》的文章。这篇文章在警务界和非警务界都引起了相当大的关注。乔治对帕洛阿尔托发生的事情着迷不已。一旦汽车遭到损坏，事情的发展就和在布朗克斯一模一样。这种想法是，一旦无序开始，无论是什么社区，事情都可能开始失控。乔治推断，整个社区也可能存在同样的情况。
A broken window in a neighborhood sends the signal that the neighborhood is uncared for. So if police departments address the little crimes and misdemeanors that might create visible signs of disorder, maybe, just maybe, the bigger stuff wouldn't happen either. Once you begin to deal with the small problems in neighborhoods, you begin to empower those neighborhoods. And people claim their public spaces and store owners,
社区里的一扇破窗户发出了一种信号，表明这个社区无人照管。因此，如果警察局处理那些可能造成明显无序迹象的小犯罪和轻罪，也许，仅仅是也许，更大的事情也不会发生。一旦你开始处理社区中的小问题，你就会开始赋权这些社区。人们夺回他们的公共空间，店主们，
extend their concerns to what happened on the streets, residents control park spaces, communities get strengthened once order is restored or maintained, and it is that dynamic that helps to prevent crime. This wasn't what many police departments were doing. Officers were focused on solving major crimes. Georgianist co-author suggested police departments ought to change their focus. They ought to clean up the streets, keep people from smoking pot in public, crack down on subway
将他们的关切延伸到街道上发生的事情，居民们控制公园空间，社区在恢复或维持秩序后得到加强，正是这种动态有助于预防犯罪。这并不是许多警察部门当时在做的事情。警官们的重点是破获重大案件。乔治和他的合著者建议警察部门应该改变他们的工作重点。他们应该整顿街道，阻止人们在公共场所吸大麻，打击地铁
fairbeaters. As it turned out, this was exactly what many communities wanted. If right now we were to go to some neighborhood meeting about problems in the neighborhood, at least three, and probably four of those will be problems of disorder. And that is, use taking over a park, prostitutes, hustling fathers and front of their children, drug dealers hanging around corners. Those are the kinds of things that comprise a good share of the calls that come to police departments and
逃票行为。事实证明，这正是许多社区想要的。如果现在我们去参加某个关于社区问题的社区会议，其中至少有三个，很可能是四个，都将是无序问题。也就是说，年轻人占领公园，妓女，在孩子面前拉客的父亲，在街角闲晃的毒贩。这些正是构成警察部门接到的报警电话中很大一部分的事情，并
demand that's based on police to do something about these problems. The argument came at an opportune time. This was a period of high crime and high incarceration and it seemed as if there was no way out of that dynamic and it seemed as if there was no way out of just filling prisons as a way to address the crime problem. This is Bernhard Hartquart, professor of law at Columbia University. As policymakers was scrambling for answers to crime, a new mayor in New York came to power
形成了要求警察对这些问题采取行动的需求。这一论点提出的时机恰到好处。这是一个高犯罪率和高监禁率的时期，当时似乎摆脱这种动态已经无路可走，而且似乎除了用填满监狱作为应对犯罪问题的方法之外别无他路。这是哥伦比亚大学法学教授伯纳德·哈考特。当决策者们争先恐后地寻找应对犯罪的答案时，纽约的一位新市长上台了，
offering a solution. Ladies and gentlemen, the mayor of the city of New York, Rudolf W. Giuliani. Rudy Giuliani won election in 1993, promising to reduce crime and clean up the streets. Very quickly, he adopted broken windows as his mantra. It was one of those rare ideas that appealed to people on both sides of the aisle. Consovatives liked the policy because it meant restoring order, and liberals liked it, Bernard says, because it seemed like an enlightened way to prevent crime. All of a sudden, it seems as if, well, instead of, you know, throwing people in prison and cracking down, all you really had to do was just pick up the trash and get rid of a homeless person and fix an
并提供了一个解决方案。女士们先生们，纽约市市长鲁道夫·W·朱利安尼。鲁迪·朱利安尼在1993年赢得选举，承诺减少犯罪并整顿街道。很快，他将“破窗”奉为圭臬。这是那种罕见的能够吸引两党民众的理念。保守派喜欢这项政策，因为它意味着恢复秩序；伯纳德说，自由主义者喜欢它，因为它看起来像是预防犯罪的一种开明方式。突然之间，似乎，嗯，与其说是，你知道的，把人们投进监狱并进行严厉打击，你真正需要做的其实只是捡起垃圾，赶走无家可归的人，修好一个
abandoned building, just these small forms of disorder. That course were pretty widespread in a city like New York. Rudy Giuliani and his new police commissioner, William Bratton, focused first on cleaning up the subway system. George Kelly again. Here was a system that was entirely out of control. Writership was dropping. Lawlessness rained in the subway,
废弃的建筑，仅仅是这些小形式的无序。这些现象在纽约这样的城市当然相当普遍。鲁迪·朱利安尼和他的新任警察局长威廉·布拉顿首先将重点放在整顿地铁系统上。再次请出乔治·凯林。这是一个彻底失控的系统。乘客量在下降。地铁里无法无天，
and 250,000 people a day weren't being there fair. The mayor and the police commissioner sent hundreds of police officers into the subway to crack down on turn-style jumpers and vandals. Very quickly, they found confirmation for their theory. Going off to petty crime led the police to violent criminals. In some station it was found that as many as one in ten people who were not paying the fare were either wanted on a warrant for a felony or were carrying
每天有25,000人逃票。市长和警察局长派遣了数百名警察进入地铁，打击跳闸和破坏者。很快，他们为自己的理论找到了佐证。打击轻罪使警察找到了暴力罪犯。在一些车站发现，多达十分之一逃票的人要么是被通缉的重罪犯，要么携带了
an illegal weapon. Not all fair beaters were criminals but a lot of criminals were fair beaters. It turns out that serious criminals are pretty busy. They commit minor offenses as well as major offenses. The policy was quickly scaled up from the subway system to the entire city of New York. Police ramped up misdemeanor arrests for things like smoking marijuana and public, spraying graffiti, selling loose cigarettes. Almost instantly, they were able to trumpet their success. Crime was falling.
非法武器。并非所有逃票者都是罪犯，但很多罪犯都逃过票。事实证明，重罪犯相当忙碌。他们既犯轻罪，也犯重罪。这项政策很快从地铁系统推广到整个纽约市。警察加大了对诸如在公共场所吸大麻、喷涂涂鸦、兜售散装香烟等轻罪的逮捕力度。几乎瞬间，他们就得以大肆宣扬自己的成功。犯罪率在下降。
The murder rate plummeted. It seemed like a miracle. The media loved the story. At first, people laughed when he launched a politeness campaign. We begin with sociologist George Kelly and his ideas about how to reduce serious crime by restoring public ordering communities. It's called broken windows go after quality of life offenses to help reduce bigger crimes. George Kelly and another researcher found what they believed was clear evidence of the success
谋杀率骤降。这看起来像个奇迹。媒体非常喜欢这个故事。起初，当他发起文明礼貌运动时，人们都笑了。我们从社会学家乔治·凯林及其关于如何通过恢复社区公共秩序来减少严重犯罪的理念开始谈起。这被称为破窗效应——打击生活质量犯罪以帮助减少更大的犯罪。乔治·凯林和另一位研究人员发现了他们认为是成功的明确证据
of broken windows. In neighborhoods where there was a sharp increase in misdemeanor arrests, suggesting broken windows policing was enforced, there was also a sharp decline in crime. By the time Rudy Giuliani was giving his farewell address at the end of 2001, broken windows had become one of his greatest accomplishments. The reality is that the motto that was adopted for dealing with crime in New York City is the very, very best way to assure that you can keep a city safe. The mayor emphasized the beautiful and simple idea behind the success.
的“破窗”。在轻罪逮捕人数急剧增加（表明破窗警务得到了执行）的社区，犯罪率也出现了急剧下降。到鲁迪·朱利安尼在2001年底发表告别演说时，“破窗”已经成为他最伟大的成就之一。现实情况是，为应对纽约市犯罪而采用的座右铭是确保你能保证城市安全的最最好、最有效的方法。市长强调了成功背后的美好而简单的理念。
The broken windows theory replaced the idea that we were too busy to pay attention to street level prostitution, too busy to pay attention to panhandling, to busy to pay attention to graffiti. Well, you can't be too busy to pay attention to those things because those are the things that underlie the problems of crime that you have in your society. In less than a decade, New York was transformed. That's right. Yeah, everything's going well. If you're on the upper east side.
“破窗”理论取代了这样一种观点：我们太忙而无暇关注街头卖淫，太忙而无暇关注乞讨，太忙而无暇关注涂鸦。好吧，你不可能忙得无暇关注这些事情，因为这些事情正是你社会中存在的犯罪问题的根源。在不到十年的时间里，纽约发生了脱胎换骨的变化。没毛病。是的，一切都进展顺利。如果你在上东区的话。
But not hardcore again. Of course, it's going a lot less well if you're in other boroughs or in other neighborhoods where all of the policing and all of the arrests are taking place. As broken windows policing was coming into force, some critics said it unfairly targeted communities of color. When we come back, we'll talk it unfairly targeted communities of color. When we come back, we'll talk about this idea and a deeper problem. Broken windows may not have been quite the raging success we thought it was.
但伯纳德·哈考特再次指出。当然，如果你在其他行政区或在所有的警务和逮捕行动都在发生的其他社区，情况就远没有那么好了。随着“破窗”警务开始实施，一些批评人士表示，它不公平地针对有色人种社区。当我们回来时，我们将讨论它不公平地针对有色人种社区。当我们回来时，我们将讨论这个理念以及一个更深层次的问题。“破窗”可能并不像我们想象的那样是一场狂暴的成功。
It's a very sugar-coated idea that would it be true, it would be marvelous. Stay with us. The rise of broken windows policing and the dramatic fall and crime made for a beautiful story. But right from the start, there was signs something was wrong with the beautiful narrative. Crime was starting to go down in New York prior to the Giuliani election and prior to the implementation of broken windows policing.
这是一个非常粉饰的理念，如果它是真的，那将是极好的。请继续收听。“破窗”警务的兴起和犯罪率的急剧下降构成了一个美好的故事。但从一开始，就有迹象表明这个美好的叙事有些不对劲。在朱利安尼当选之前以及“破窗”警务实施之前，纽约的犯罪率就已经开始下降了。
And of course, what we witnessed from that period and it's basically from about 91 that crime in the country starts going down is a remarkable remarkable drop in violent crime in this country. Now what's so remarkable about it is how widespread it was. So widespread in fact that crime dropped not only in New York but in many other cities where nothing like broken windows policing was in place. In fact crime even So widespread, in fact, that crime dropped not only in New York, but in many other cities, where nothing like broken windows policing was in place. In fact, crime even fell in parts of the country where police departments were mired in corruption
当然，我们从那个时期见证的——基本上是从91年左右开始，全国的犯罪率开始下降——是这个国家暴力犯罪显着的、显着的下降。现在，最引人注目的是它的普及程度。事实上如此普遍，以至于犯罪率不仅在纽约下降，而且在许多其他城市也有所下降，而那里根本没有实施类似“破窗”的警务。事实上，犯罪率甚至……事实上，如此普遍，以至于不仅在纽约，而且在许多其他城市，犯罪率也有所下降，而那里根本没有实施类似“破窗”的警务。事实上，犯罪率甚至在全国某些警察部门陷入腐败
scandals and largely seen as dysfunctional. Los Angeles was racked with terrible policing problems during the whole time. In fact, the period is a book ended on one side by the Rodney King scandal and on the other side by the ramparts scandal. In between the two, the LAPD is pretty much dysfunctional and despite the fact that the LAPD isn't doing anything, basically. I mean, it's then it's certainly not doing broken windows policing. Crime drops as much in Los Angeles as it does in New York.
丑闻且在很大程度上被视为功能失调的地区也有所下降。洛杉矶在整个这段时间里都饱受糟糕的警务问题之苦。事实上，这一时期的两端分别以罗德尼·金丑闻和兰帕特丑闻为标志。在这两者之间，洛杉矶警察局几乎已经瘫痪，尽管事实上洛杉矶警察局基本上什么也没做。我的意思是，它当时肯定没有在推行“破窗”警务。洛杉矶的犯罪率下降幅度与纽约一样大。
How could this be? Well, there are many theories. Some attribute the nationwide drop in crime to the growing economy, the end of the crack cocaine epidemic, even environmental factors. Some criminologists credit harsher sentencing guidelines. In 2006, Bernard Harcourt reviewed the study George Kelly had conducted in 2001. The earlier study had powerfully made the case that broken windows policing worked. It found that the areas that saw the largest number of misdemeanor arrests also had the biggest drops in violent crime. But it turned out that actually he had failed to include in his study a very common explanation
这怎么可能呢？嗯，有很多理论。有些人将全国犯罪率的下降归因于经济增长、快克可卡因流行的结束，甚至是环境因素。一些犯罪学家则将此归功于更严厉的量刑指南。2006年，伯纳德·哈考特审阅了乔治·凯林在2001年进行的研。早期的研究有力地证明了“破窗”警务是奏效的。它发现轻罪逮捕人数最多的地区，暴力犯罪率下降幅度也最大。但事实证明，实际上他在研究中漏掉了一个非常普遍的解释，
which is called a reversion to the mean. And it's something that's well known in the stock market, but basically the idea is, you know, if something goes up a lot, it tends to go down a lot. A graph in George Kelly's 2001 paper is revealing. It shows the crime rate falling dramatically in the early 1990s. But this window of time gives us its selective picture. Right before this decline came a spike in crime. And if you go further back, you see a series of spikes and declines.
那就是所谓的“均值回归”。这是股票市场中广为人知的一个概念，但其基本思想是，你知道的，如果某样东西涨得很高，它往往就会跌得很多。乔治·凯林2001年论文中的一张图表很有启示意义。它显示犯罪率在20世纪90年代初急剧下降。但这段时间窗口给我们提供了一幅有选择性的画卷。就在这次下降之前，犯罪率曾出现过飙升。如果你再往前看，你会看到一系列的飙升和下降。
And each time the bigger a spike, the bigger the decline that follows, as crime reverts to the mean. George Kelly acknowledges that broken windows may not have had a dramatic effect on crime, but he still thinks it has value. Even if broken windows did not have a substantial impact on crime, order is an end in itself in a cosmopolitan, diverse world. Strangers have to feel comfortable moving through communities for those communities to thrive. Order is an end in itself, and it doesn't
每一次，飙升得越高，随之而来的下降也就越大，因为犯罪率会回归均值。乔治·凯林承认，“破窗”可能并未对犯罪产生巨大影响，但他仍然认为它有价值。即使“破窗”没有对犯罪产生实质性影响，在一个多元化的国际化世界里，秩序本身就是目的。对于这些社区的繁荣而言，陌生人必须感到在社区中穿行是舒适的。秩序本身就是目的，它不需要
need the justification of serious crime. But it's worth noting that this was not the premise on which the theory was sold. Broken windows policing was advertised as an innovative way to control violent crime, not just a way to get panhandlers and prostitutes off the streets. There was also another big problem with broken windows. Here's Bernard Harcourt again. We immediately saw an increase, a sharp increase in complaints of police misconduct.
严重犯罪作为正当理由。但值得注意的是，这并不是推销该理论的前提。“破窗”警务被宣传为控制暴力犯罪的创新方式，而不仅仅是将乞丐和妓女赶出街道的一种方法。“破窗”还存在另一个大问题。再次请出伯纳德·哈考特。我们立即看到了警察不当行为投诉的增加，急剧增加。
And that's actually one of the most interesting things about the period, really, from 1993 to 96, for instance, when Giuliani is implementing the Quality of Life Initiative. We always associated it with greater order, because crime dropped 60%, but complaints of police misconduct increased by 60%. And so you might wonder, well, actually, was it a period of greater order, or was it a period of greater disorder? And of course, this reflects the fact that the notion of orderliness is itself constructed by us and by what we focus on. But if you focus on police civilian relations, starting in 1993,
事实上，这是这一时期最有趣的事情之一，例如从1993年到96年，当朱利安尼实施“生活质量倡议”时。我们总是把它与更大的秩序联系在一起，因为犯罪率下降了60%，但对警察不当行为的投诉却增加了60%。所以你可能会想，嗯，实际上，这到底是一个更有秩序的时期，还是一个更加混乱的时期？当然，这反映了这样一种事实：秩序的概念本身就是由我们以及我们所关注的事物构建的。但是，如果你关注警察与平民的关系，从1993年开始，
what you're going to see is a tremendous amount of disorder that erupts as a result of broken windows policing. With complaints skyrocketing, with settlements of police misconduct cases, skyrocketing, and of police misconduct cases skyrocketing and of course with incidents brutal incidents all of a sudden happening at a faster and faster clip. The problem intensified with a new practice that grew out of broken windows it was called stop and frisk. It was embraced in New York City after Mayor Michael Bloomberg won election in 2001. If broken windows meant arresting people for misdemeanors in
你将会看到的是，由于“破窗”警务而爆发的大量无序混乱。投诉量飙升，警察不当行为案件的和解金飙升，警察不当行为案件飙升，当然，暴力事件和粗暴事件也突然以越来越快的速度发生。随着一种从“破窗”中衍生出的新做法，这个问题加剧了，它被称为“拦截搜查”。在迈克尔·布隆伯格市长于2001年赢得选举后，它在纽约市得到了采纳。如果说“破窗”意味着为了预防更严重的犯罪而逮捕轻罪人员，那么“拦截搜查”则在说，为什么还要等轻罪发生呢？为什么不直接去拦截、
hopes of preventing more serious crimes, stop and frisk said, why even wait for the misdemeanor? Why not go ahead and stop? Question, search, anyone who looks suspicious. Once Bloomberg became mayor, he turned from a policy of high misdemeanor arrests to a policy of stop and frisk. They substitute for each other because both of them provide something to the police that the police feels is necessary, which is to be able to come up to an individual, ask them questions, do it some kind of a search, whether it's a pat down or a full search upon arrest, possibly do a records check, check for warrants, etc. And so what it does is it gets a lot more
盘问、搜查任何看起来可疑的人呢。一旦布隆伯格当选市长，他便从严厉打击轻罪的政策转向了拦截搜查政策。它们彼此替代，因为这两者都向警察提供了警察认为必要的东西，那就是能够走到一个人面前，向他们询问问题，进行某种搜查，无论是拍身搜查还是逮捕时的全面搜查，可能还要进行背景调查、核查是否有逮捕令等等。因此，它为警察带来了更多的
information to the police. You make more informants, you can get fingerprints, and those things are from a policing perspective, those things are always going to be useful. There were high profile cases where misdemeanor arrests or stopping and questioning did lead to information that helped solve much more serious crimes, even homicides. But there were many, many more cases where the police stops turned up nothing. In 2008, police made nearly 250,000 stops in New York for what they called, furtive movements. The police did find guns during these stops, but the numbers might surprise you. Only one-fifteenth of one percent turned up a gun.
信息。你可以培养更多的线人，你可以获得指纹，从警务的角度来看，这些东西永远都是有用的。确实有一些备受瞩目的案例，在这些案例中，轻罪逮捕或拦截盘问确实带来了有助于破获更严重犯罪（甚至是凶杀案）的信息。但还有更多更多的案例，警察的拦截什么也没查出来。2008年，警察在纽约以所谓的“鬼祟行为”为由进行了近25万次拦截。警察确实在这些拦截中发现了枪支，但这个数字可能会让你大吃一惊。只有十五分之一的一个百分点搜出了枪支。
Even more problematic, in order to be able to go after disorder, you have to be able to define it. Is it a trash bag covering a broken window? Teenagers on a street corner playing music too loudly? In Chicago, the researchers Robert Samson and Stephen Routenbush, analyzed what makes people perceive social disorder. They found that if two neighborhoods had exactly the same amount of graffiti and litter and loitering, people saw more disorder, more broken windows, in neighborhoods
更具问题的是，为了能够打击无序现象，你必须能够定义它。是覆盖破窗户的垃圾袋吗？是在街角把音乐放得很大声的 teenagers（青少年）吗？在芝加哥，研究人员罗伯特·萨姆森和斯蒂芬·鲁登布施分析了是什么让人感知到社会无序。他们发现，如果两个社区有完全相同数量的涂鸦、垃圾和闲逛人员，人们会在黑人人口较多的社区看到更多的无序现象、更多的破窗户。
with more African Americans. It was, I think, a Wednesday or a Thursday night. I was coming home from dinner with a friend. This is Jamal Johnson, he's African-American 40 years old. I'd noticed an increased police presence in the neighborhood because after we had dinner, we literally came across something like nine or ten different cops in about a three-block radius. Jamal was walking with his friend, but eventually the two split off.
那我想应该是一个星期三或星期四的晚上。我和一个朋友吃完晚饭正往家走。这是贾马尔·约翰逊，他是一名40岁的非裔美国人。我注意到社区里的警察变多了，因为我们吃完晚饭后，在大概三个街区的半径内，确实遇到了差不多九到十个不同的警察。贾马尔正和他的朋友散步，但最终两人分开了。
And as I was walking on a street, I noticed the cops looking at us, but not really paying us much attention after the initial sort of scan. And then as I rounded the corner to my block, there was police officer on the corner, and at that stage I was by myself, and of course at that stage, I got stopped. of course at that stage I got stopped.
当我在街上走时，我注意到警察在看我们，但在最初那种打量之后，并没有真的把太多注意力放在我们身上。然后，当我拐弯走到我所在的街区时，街角站着一名警察，当时我独自一人，当然就在那个时候，我被拦下了。当然就在那个时候，我被拦下了。
Jemal was carrying a small utility knife. He was a filmmaker and it came in handy on set. I had come from a day of work and I was working on a photo shoot and a police officer noticed that I had had my work knife, which I know to be street legal, but which he sort of asked me to take out and and show to him. And then he asked me for my ID. He then called, he called in a dispatch, once he'd had my ID, he asked me some basic questions about where I lived, what my job was, what I was doing with it with my evening and so forth. And when he couldn't reach dispatch, he then started to take down
贾马尔随身带着一把小型多功能刀。他是一名电影制作人，这在片场能派上用场。我刚结束一天的工作，当时正在参与一个照片拍摄项目，一名警察注意到我带着工作刀，我知道这在街头是合法的，但他某种程度上要求我拿出来展示给他看。接着他向我要了身份证。然后他呼叫了，他呼叫了调度台，一旦他拿到了我的身份证，他就问了我一些基本问题，比如我住在哪里，我的工作是什么，我打算怎么度过这个夜晚等等。当他无法联系到调度台时，他便开始记录
my information at which stage I said to him, please don't put me in the system, you know, you know that I live right here. And you also know that my knife, my knife is legal at which point he said that the knife wasn't in fact legal. And then he asked me if I wanted to, if I preferred to go to jail to To which I said, I think you can understand why I wouldn't like to be in the system. I also think you know that I don't want to go to jail tonight. At which point he said, well, don't give me a hard time. My response was, excuse me, sir.
我的信息，这时我对他说：“请不要把我录入系统，你知道的，你知道我就住在这里。你也知道我的刀，我的刀是合法的。”此时他说这把刀事实上并不合法。然后他问我是否想，是否宁愿去坐牢。对此我说：“我想你能理解为什么我不想被录入系统。我也认为你知道我今晚不想去坐牢。”此时他说：“好吧，别给我找麻烦。”我的回应是：“不好意思，先生。
I certainly didn't mean to do that. Thank you. At which stage, he took down my info, told me not to have my knife on me again, and then let me go home with a sort of a sour look. I think it's worse than humiliation to me because it's not personal. And to me, that's worse because when your society can detain you, won't let you speak to them, you know, like in a sense that the guy said,
我当然不是故意要找麻烦。谢谢。”就在这时，他记下了我的信息，告诉我以后不要随身携带这把刀，然后带着一种酸溜溜的表情让我回家了。我认为这对我来说比羞辱还要糟糕，因为它不是针对个人的。对我来说，这更糟糕，因为当你的社会可以拘留你，不让你和他们说话，你知道的，就像那家伙说的那样，
you know, essentially, why are you talking back to me? When that becomes your relationship with your society, that means that your life or the very least, like your livelihood, like you getting to and from work, is that question. So I don't really necessarily need to feel huge moments of pride from every interaction I have with the police, but I certainly need to feel that my life or even my evening and my police record isn't
你知道的，基本上就是“你为什么顶嘴？”当这成为了你与社会的关系时，这就意味着你的生活，或者至少是你的生计，比如你上下班通勤，都成了问题。所以，我不一定非得从我与警察的每一次互动中感受到巨大的自豪感，但我绝对需要感觉到我的生活，甚至我的夜晚和我的警察记录，不会
in danger just arbitrarily. So that feeling of an impersonal, not friendly government, standing over you, is pretty terrible. George Kelling is not an advocate of stop and frisk. In fact, all the way back in 1982, he foresaw the possibility that giving police wide discretion could lead to abuse. In our interview, I read him a passage from that article that is proven to be prescient.
随随便便地陷入危险。因此，那种冷冰冰的、不友好的政府高高在上的感觉，是非常糟糕的。乔治·凯林并不是“拦截搜查”的主张者。事实上，早在1982年，他就预见到了赋予警察广泛自由裁量权可能会导致滥用的可能性。在我们的采访中，我向他朗读了那篇文章中的一段话，事实证明这段话具有先见之明。
We might agree that certain behavior makes one person more undesirable than another, but how do we ensure that age or skin color or national origin or harmless mannerisms will not also become the basis for distinguishing the undesirable from the desirable. How do we ensure in short that the police do not become the agents of neighborhood bigotry? We can offer no holy satisfactory answer to this important question. Yeah, that's a loaded statement. And it's something that I've struggled with.
我们或许可以认同某种行为会让一个人比另一个人更令人讨厌，但我们如何确保年龄、肤色、国籍或无害的癖好不会同样成为区分不受欢迎者与受欢迎者的基础？简而言之，我们如何确保警察不会成为社区偏见的代理人？对于这个重要问题，我们无法给出令人十分满意的答案。是的，这是一个很有分量且充满争议的陈述。这也是我一直在与之挣扎的事情。
In August of 2013, a federal district court found that New York's stop and frisk policy was unconstitutional, because of the way it singled out young, black, and Hispanic men. Later that year, New York elected its first liberal mayor in 20 years. Build a Blasio celebrated the end of stop and frisk. Public safety is a prerequisite for the thriving neighborhoods
2013年8月，联邦地区法院裁定，纽约的“拦截搜查”政策违宪，因为它针对年轻的黑人和西班牙裔男子的方式具有歧视性。同年晚些时候，纽约选举出了20年来第一位自由派市长。白思豪庆祝了“拦截搜查”的结束。公共安全是这个城市创造机遇的繁荣社区的先决条件。
that create opportunity in this city. And so is respect for civil liberties. We are all hungry for an approach that acknowledges we are stronger and safer as a city, when police and residents work hand in hand. But he did not do away with broken windows. In fact, he reappointed Rudy Giuliani's police commissioner, Bill Bratton. It is a great day for New York City because I am proud to announce that I am appointing Bill Bratton as the next police commissioner of the city of New York. Just seven months after taking over again as the head of New York's police department, Bill Bratton's use of broken windows tactics came under fresh scrutiny.
对公民自由的尊重也是如此。我们都渴望有一种方法，承认当我们警民齐心协力时，我们的城市会更强大、更安全。但他并没有废除“破窗”政策。事实上，他重新任命了鲁迪·朱利安尼的警察局长比尔·布拉顿。对纽约市来说这是伟大的一天，因为我很自豪地宣布，我将任命比尔·布拉顿为纽约市下一任警察局长。就在重新接掌纽约市警察局仅仅七个月后，比尔·布拉顿对“破窗”战术的使用再次受到了严格审查。
In this video, shot on a bystander cell phone on a sunny July day in New York City in 2014, a man is standing on the sidewalk between two police officers. Several more officers are just outside of the frame. The cops are asking the man whether he was selling loose cigarettes, misdemeanor The man is visibly and audibly upset This is not the first time he has been questioned by police and Then the officers tackle him they bring him to the ground while restraining him with a chokehold a practice that is banned in New York City. The man in the video is Eric Garner. He's African American and his name has become synonymous with the growing distrust between
这段视频拍摄于2014年纽约市一个阳光明媚的7月天，由路人用手机拍摄。画面中，一名男子站在纽约市街头两名警察之间。几名警察正站在画面外。警察正在盘问这名男子是否在兜售散装香烟，这属于轻罪。这名男子显得情绪激动，肉眼可见也听得出来。这不是他第一次遭到警察盘问，随后警察将他扑倒。他们将他按倒在地，同时用扼喉的方式制服他——这种做法在纽约市是被禁止的。视频中的男子是埃里克·加纳。他是非裔美国人，他的名字已经成为警察与非裔美国人社区之间日益加深的互不信任的代名词。
police and African American communities. He died not long after the interaction you just heard. Commissioner Bill Bratton found himself on the fire from the media not only about Eric Garner's death, but the entire philosophy of broken windows. Here he is talking with CBS News anchor Maurice Dubois in 2014. Commissioner, critics are blaming your broken windows policy. It's been a hail all around the world is successful going after low-level crimes before big ones happen okay so in this case many people are upset however because they feel
他在你刚刚听到的互动不久后死亡。警察局长比尔·布拉顿发现自己不仅因为埃里克·加纳的死而遭到媒体的猛烈抨击，而且还面临着整个“破窗”哲学的质疑。在这里，他正与CBS新闻主播莫里斯·杜布瓦在2014年进行对话。局长，批评人士正在指责你的“破窗”政策。它在世界各地都被誉为在重大犯罪发生之前打击低级别犯罪的成功举措。好吧，所以在这种情况下，许多人感到不满，然而因为他们觉得
it's targeting communities of color how do you respond to that we are not targeting communities to call out we are targeting behavior in the behavior is for George Kelly this was not the end that he had hoped for. As a researcher, he's one of the few whose ideas have left the academy and spread like wildfire. But once politicians and the media fell in love with his idea, they took it to places that he never intended and could not control. When during the 1990s, broken windows was a hot ticket item.
它针对的是有色人种社区，你对此有何回应？我们没有针对有色人种社区，我们针对的是行为，而这种行为是……对乔治·凯林来说，这并不是他所希望的结局。作为一名研究人员，他是少数几个其理念走出学术界并像野火一样蔓延的人之一。但一旦政客和媒体爱上了他的想法，他们就把它带到了他从未预料到且无法控制的地方。在20世纪90年代，“破窗”是个大热门。
I would occasionally read in the newspaper something like, a new chief comes in and says, I just read broken windows and I'm going to implement broken windows tomorrow. I won't repeat the magic words that go through my mind because we're on the air. But I would listen to that with dismay. Dismay, because he worried that many officials were so enamored with the simplicity of the broken windows metaphor
我偶尔会在报纸上读到类似这样的话：一个新的局长上任，然后说：“我刚读了《破窗》，明天我就要实施‘破窗’。”我不重复掠过我脑海的那些神奇字眼了，因为我们在直播。但我会带着沮丧的心情听着这些。沮丧，是因为他担心许多官员对“破窗”隐喻的简单性如此着迷，
that they were not willing to stop and think about the nuances. He worried that officers who hadn't received enough training were being asked to exercise discretion and make complex judgments on the very high pressure. And so do I worry about the implementation about broken windows a whole lot? Yes, I worry about the implementation of order maintenance because it can be done very badly. It's to the point now where I wonder if we should back away from the metaphor of broken
以至于他们不愿意停下来思考其中的细微差别。他担心那些没有接受足够培训的警察被要求在巨大压力下行使自由裁量权并做出复杂的判断。所以，我非常担心“破窗”的实施吗？是的，我很担心维护秩序的实施，因为这可能会搞得很糟糕。现在的情况已经到了这样的地步：我在想我们是否应该摒弃“破窗”这个隐喻。
windows. Broken windows was a powerful metaphor. Jim and I used it. We didn't know how powerful it was going to be. It simplified. It was easy to communicate. A lot of people got it as a result of the metaphor. It was attractive.
“破窗”是一个强有力的隐喻。我和吉姆使用了它。我们当时并不知道它会产生多大的威力。它被简化了。它易于传达。由于这个隐喻，很多人理解了它。它很有吸引力。
And it carried us for a long time. But as you know, metaphors can wear out and become stale. These days, the consensus among social scientists is that broken windows likely did have modest effects on crime, but few believe it caused the 60 or 70% decline in violent crime that it's often credited with. Despite all the evidence, broken windows continues to be popular. Bernhard Hartcourt says there's a reason for that. It's a simple story that people can latch onto and that then is a lot more pleasant to live with than the
它支撑了我们很长一段时间。但正如你所知，隐喻也会磨损并变得陈旧。如今，社会科学家的共识是，“破窗”可能确实对犯罪产生了轻微的影响，但很少有人相信它导致了人们通常归功于它的暴力犯罪60%或70%的下降。尽管有种种证据，“破窗”依然很受欢迎。伯纳德·哈考特表示，这是有原因的。这是一个人们可以抓住的简单故事，相比于生活的复杂性，
complexities of life. The fact is that crime dropped in America dramatically from the 1990s and that there aren't really good, clean, nation-wide explanations for it. The story of broken windows is a story of our fascination with easy fixes and seductive theories. Once an idea like that takes hold, it's nearly impossible to get the genie back in the bottle. This episode of the Hidden Brain Podcast was produced by Maggie Pennman and edited by Jenny Schmidt. Our team includes Brenna Clar and Raina Cohen. Our supervising producer is Tara Boyle. Our unsung hero this week is Jenna Weissberman. She's a producer who used
与它共存要愉快得多。事实是，自20世纪90年代以来，美国的犯罪率急剧下降，并且对此并没有真正好且干净利落的全国性解释。“破窗”的故事是我们对简单修复和诱人理论着迷的故事。一旦这样一个理念扎根，几乎就不可能再把精灵放回瓶子里了。本期《隐藏的大脑》播客由玛吉·彭曼制作，珍妮·史密斯剪辑。我们的团队包括布伦娜·克拉尔和雷娜·科恩。我们的监督制作人是塔拉·博伊尔。我们本周的无名英雄是珍娜·韦斯伯曼。她是一位曾经
to work at NPR and she played an important role in getting the Hidden Brain Podcast off the ground. Jenna contributed a lot of reporting to this episode. Over the next few weeks we're going to bring you other stories exploring how race, immigration and religion intersect with politics, policing and the media. Next week we look at new research that asks whether a psychological test can predict how police will interact with people of color. Please subscribe to the podcast to make sure you get that episode.
在NPR工作的制作人，她在让《隐藏的大脑》播客顺利起步方面发挥了重要作用。珍娜为本期节目贡献了大量的报道。在接下来的几周里，我们将为你带来其他故事，探讨种族、移民和宗教如何与政治、警务和媒体交织在一起。下周我们将关注一项新的研究，该研究探讨心理测试是否能够预测警察将如何与有色人种互动。请订阅本期播客以确保收到该集节目。
We're looking forward to having you join us. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们期待你的加入。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。